مشاهده مرحبا بكم في مجال من قناه الجزيره
اعلان المتحدث باسم هيئه الانتخابات في
تونس محمد دليلي المصري انا نسبه الاقتراع
في الانتخابات البرلمانيه حتى السادسه
مساء بتوقيت المحلي بلغت ثمانيه وثمانيه
اعشار في المئه وقال المنصري نتائج
الانتخابات متواضعه لكنها غير مخجله
وبينما رحبت حركه النهضه بما وصفته
بالموقف الشعبي من الانتخابات قالت جبهه
الخلاص ان نسبه المشاركه ان هاتف ما وصفته
بالمسرحيه وان رئيس قيس سعيد فقد شرعيته
متعهده بعزله وده عبد الرزاق الخلولي رئيس
المكتب السياسي لحرك الخامس والعشرين من
يوليو مساند للرئيس سعيد الى انتخابات
الرئاسيه مبكرا
اعلنت القوات الاوكرانيه حاله التاهب
الجوي في عموم البلاد محذره من موجه هجمات
الروسيه جديده وقالت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان نحو 25 قريه اخرى في مدينه
في محيط مدينه محمود تعرضت لقصف روسيا
كثيف
وقال الزعيم الانفصاليين في دنيا ان قواته
بالتعاون مع مجموعه تقترب من احكام الحصار
على المدينه وان القوات الاوكرانيه تدفع
بتعزيزات كبيره نحو المدينه التي تشد
المعارك عند اطرافها حسب تعبيره
مصادر المحليه للجزيره بان المدفعيه الجيش
التركي استهدفت مواقع لما تعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه في قريتي الشيخ علي
وقدليه في تل تمر شمال الحسكه وفي قريه
رقاص بريفيا الرقه ما اسفر عن مقتل طفل
واصابه اخرين
بحسب ما قالت مواقع اعلاميه كرديه فقالت
وزاره الدفاع التركيه انه للعراق ولا
سوريا سيكون امنا لمن سمتهم الارهابيين
اعتبرت الخارجيه الروسيه العمليه البريه
التركيه المرتقبه في سوريا سابقه لاوانها
وانها قد تؤدي الى مزيد من التصعيد اشاره
الخارجيه الروسيه لان الناس قد تتفهم ما
خوف انقره لكنها تنطلق من الحاجه الى
ضروره التقييد الصارم بمبادئ وحده اراضي
الدوله السوريه واستقلالها هو سيادتها
قال مكتب محافظ القدس الى شابين فلسطينيين
شقيقين استشهد في حادث في دهس متعمد
ارتكبهم مستوطن الاسرائيلي والقربه حاجزي
زعتر العسكري جنوب نابلس بالضفه الغربيه
المحتله اضافه للمصدر ان الشاب بين محمد
ومهند مطير من مخيم قلنديا للاجئين كان هي
ثاني على جانب الطريق
سيارتهما عندما صدمهما مستوطنهم
الاستراليهم سيارته عمدا ما ادى لمصر على
احدهما فورا ونقفل الثاني للمستشفى حيث
توفي لاحقا وقد كانت فصاله وطنيه فلسطينيه
جريمه الدهس ودعت الى الصعيد المقاومه ضد
الاحتلال
انت هذا الموجز شكرا لكم اينما كنتم في
امان
[موسيقى]